netanyahu as prime minister after
israeli parliament votes to form a new
coalition government he's out
as prime minister business insider story
the israeli parliament on sunday voted
to form a new coalition government
unseating prime minister benjamin
netanyahu
who has led the country for the last 12
years naftali bennett a long time
netanyahu ally
turned adversary assumed the role of
prime minister and was sworn in sunday
bennett is the head of the country's
right-wing
yamana party and is an ultra-nationalist
multi-millionaire according to the ap
netanyahu sat quietly during the vote
after the vote he shook bennett's hand
and briefly sat on opposition's leaders
chair before he walked out of the
chamber so that's how much we have here
in the story adam what's really going on
there okay so what's going on here and i
got a lot of notes here
and i'll try to break this down into
three major parts so obviously
israel and everything that was happening
in gaza has been all up in the news for
the last couple months
uh but everything that's been going on
with bb netanyahu has really
a couple of years they've been trying to
get him out of office and
12 years he's been in power that's a
long time especially for a democracy
so let me start off with saying this i'm
very pro-israel the more that i've dug
deeper into the subject look where
israel is look who its neighbors are
to the north you've got lebanon and
syria stable no
to the right you've got jordan pretty
stable south egypt pretty unstable
you get iran you've got afghanistan
you've got saudi arabia
name one of those countries if you're an
american the map of israel while
the audience can name one of those
countries if you're an american
and you and you're pro-american that has
your back that has your best interest
out of any of those countries you can
name one israel
so they're the only democracy in the
middle east they're in the
literally the most dangerous part of the
world you've
come from iran you understand how deidre
is up there people don't understand that
the sunnis are fighting with the shiites
and then you get the kurds
and you got different sects and
different um types of people and the
fact that israel in the middle of all
that is a democracy
that should just tell you everything you
need to know about democracy are they
perfect no
do they have issues in the country just
like america yes
that moves on to this to the second
thing um
they have issues in this country just
like on america there's trump and then
on the left
you know you've got biotin and you got
obama and then you've got aoc and on the
right you got ted cruz
essentially the best way to understand
israeli politics is let's use
american politics to basically
understand what's going on there
netanyahu was trump
okay he's been in power for a long time
is it trump or reagan
i don't i mean he was i mean i'm just
using modern times he's more of a trump
type of
ultra nationalist um
you know sort of hardline because that
that that's that if
for the person that doesn't know if you
say netanyahu is trump
they go to one place so they seem more
of a extreme like personality like a
trumpet
he's a little he's a little more stoic
than a trump if you you know can you say
he's more like a reagan maybe
you know he's a modern day reagan okay
so there's something that's polarizing
like trump he's very polarizing
polarizing fair enough okay yeah um
so just understand that they put a
coalition together and i'm trying to use
american terminology to break down
what's going on in israel yeah
for today's world i'm saying let's just
pretend for the sake of conversation
netanyahu was a trump okay so this
coalition government they put together
imagine if bernie sanders aoc
ilhan omar on the left teamed up with
joe biden
obama and then on the right ted cruz
mitt romney sort of the rhinos and they
all came together to form a coalition
government with one purpose and one
purpose only
to get netanyahu aka trump out of there
and they did it by a 60 to 59 margin
by one vote very slim margin
but basically it just it it's this is
the most
diverse government in israeli history
that's how much
all these sides of the spectrum left
center and right
basically said it's time for netanyahu
to go okay
so the person that's actually the prime
minister right now
um naftali bennett is actually further
right
than netanyahu so it'd be like a ted
cruz
or who's further right than trump that's
who he may be yeah sure he is now the
prime minister he's gonna be the prime
minister for two years this is person
who is very ultra nationalist sort of
even right
more right wing than netanyahu now
for the first time ever there's you know
there's a large arab contingency
in israel and this is actually the first
time that they're going to have a
play in the government that's a pretty
big deal so
there's ten like that we talked about
the tensions in gaza
that thing needs to be rectified so as
much as pro-israel as i am as much as i
am a lover of democracy as and how they
are a beacon of hope in the middle east
what what's happening in gaza is not
sustainable and what's happening with
the settlements is not sustainable
there needs to be a two-state solution
at some point
and if it takes having a coalition
government
who are maybe open to sharing ideas with
one another
rather than one hardliner in bibi
netanyahu i think that's something that
israelis are yearning for and we'll see
if they can make anything worse but it's
not going to be easy steve
anas if you guys are listening stephen
and us if you're listening to this steve
lewis just gave a hundred bucks and anas
has given a bunch of 20s today
if you guys are listening if you have
strong opinions about
the what just took place in israel put a
comment here if i'll see you if you're
on uh
and text us at 310-340-132 we may just
call you guys up if we got both of you
three one zero three four zero one one
three two go ahead tom
you know you mentioned the coalitions
and i guess this would be my question
if you have a coalition government with
all these extreme personalities and
ideas and your one objective
is to get a guy out and you achieve that
how do you govern
because now you're on opposite ends of
the spectrum and now you have to run a
country and you have to face some very
serious issues like iran
exactly and what's going on you know as
far as trying to prevent them from
having a nuclear bomb
which is what netanyahu passionately did
by the way didn't netanyahu say he'd be
reinstated by august
i think i'm just joking trump yeah
that's trump he did say
to quote arnold schwarzenegger i'll be
back yeah he did he gave an
entire speech in hebrew and he said
three words in english i'll be back so
netanyahu is not going anywhere
this is why i'm kind of given the trump
analogy i'm not saying he's as
polarizing or maybe he is as polarizing
as trump but netanyahu is a character
who has been
really powerful he seemed he seemed
extremely diplomatic
agreed to me on the world stage on the
world stage in israel he can be very
uh divisive he went scorched earth on
his exit
press conference the other day he went
scorched earth and he attacked biden
in that he went right after biden uh
regarding iran
so i'm just curious how this new
government is that's a good move i think
it's a good move yeah because
it shows strength that's for sure not
only shows strength
he's saying like you guys better keep an
eye out on what's going on with iran if
the negotiations continues with iran
because
if u.s and iran get closer who who what
place is a more dangerous place to be in
israel well because they would probably
use their damn nuke you know i mean
that's their whole
idea for having it so it'll be
interesting to see
what kind of um influence he has going
forward because you know when you're in
power for 12 years it's hard to give it
up
and and how the new coalition government
is going to handle iran
let's talk about uh our friend scott
galloway to to bring that back one of
his major
uh three categories that he said you
should focus on is relationships so
speaking of relationships netanyahu had
a pretty damn good relationship with
trump
to the fact when uh biden won election
uh you know how long it took him to call
bibi netanyahu
three weeks three weeks to call one of
your greatest allies
to call him he's probably got a rotary
phone doesn't know how to use a cell
phone maybe that's what it is
you know how long it took him to call
this naftali bennett one day
so uh the the the democratic party
here's a here's a message to all my
democratic uh
party friends here in america the
democratic party is slowly but surely
becoming the anti-israel party and
that's something that's very concerning
as someone who has voted democrat
and is pro-israel it it's it's becoming
more and more
likely that jewish people stephen i'm
going to call on us hang tight
are going to start hearing some of the
rhetoric that's coming out of the left
wing of the democratic party and saying
i can't stand for that i'm going to
start looking towards the right because
all my
orthodox jewish friends or any
conservative jewish friends they're
republicans
and 75 percent of of jews are more
liberal so if that tips
that could be an issue it could be an
issue and you're seeing a lot of folks
on the left kind of talk about what the
hell is going on over there an area that
we all agree on
stephen asks can you guys hear me yeah i
hear you well uh
uh our friends are back today steve can
you hear me as well i heard an ass can
you hear me as well
steve do we have you on i think we just
lost steve hang tight for me one second
let me call steve
uh yeah even uh what's his name you know
who's uh your call has been forward
come on steve pay the bill steve texas
does he text us but uh oh
let me see here give me one second
you know you never doubted for a second
where trump stood on israel ever
your call has been forward
okay guys if you're listening just call
that number back both of you guys will
get you on you never you never doubted
where he stood
on israel i mean he was probably the
most friendly president for
israel ever i mean ever look when you
got
the did russell brandt love trump
no did bill maher love trump no no
did did you know scott galloway did
these
people sit there and say oh trump's the
greatest thing since sliced bread no
no they're all in agreement on what's
going on right now with the democratic
party on positions they're taking like
what the hell are you doing like it's
almost like dude
what are you doing you're offending the
family you know what i mean like hey
you're not making a family look that i
don't stand for that
i understand i'm willing to defend my
side to a point but not for this
yeah i've been a die-hard laker fan for
my entire life since the day i came to
the states
i came november 28 1990. you know what
happened couple months after that
it's the bulls lakers final it's the
bulls lakers final
it's the georgia going up over sam
perkins right i
watched that on black and white tv when
that took place and i'm a die-hard laker
fan
i was devastated when the lakers lost
i've just been in the states for a few
months when i saw that game i'm like
dude this is this sucks
my team just lost to this guy named
michael apparently everybody calls him
the greatest
and that was his first championship i
watched michael win every single
championship back to back to back
rockets rockets back to back to back and
then everybody else came right after
jordan when he left
i'm a laker fan but even as a laker fan
it's the first time the last two years i
have not rooted for them because i don't
like
how the game is being manipulated into
fans we have to agree on one side just
to
support the nba and how much it's in my
face today
i can't just enjoy game anymore as a fan
i've stepped away from the team for the
current time being i may come back but
i'm not rooting for the lakers but
when they lost i said good for the sons
go win a championship do whatever you
got to be doing right
by the way who you choosing to win the
whole thing between the the teams that
are left well i got milwaukee
winning that series because of the
injuries you got milwaukee winning that
series
winning that series okay so i'm just
breaking it down round by round
uh i love atlanta they're a fun team to
watch but i think if milwaukee beats the
nets they're coming out of the east
i don't think the clippers are going to
beat utah i i think maybe there's an
issue with kawhi's knee yeah and
utah's not going to lose at home so i'm
going with the suns over utah in the
western finals and beating
the bucks in the uh nba finals give me
the suns
i'm going to take a shocker alert i'm
going to take brooklyn
even though the kyrie's hurt and that
hardin is uh hasn't been back yet
i know you said that they had a zero
percent chance tom uh but
as long as one one of those two guys are
healthy
kevin durant looks ridiculous right now
so i'm talking i'm hoping milwaukee wins
i'm hoping milwaukee wins is who i'm
hoping for
uh uh is what i want to see back to your
analogy with why you're you know you've
been a lifelong lakers fan and now for
the last few years you're not exactly
rooting for the lakers i'm sure your
fans are going through that right now i
think
i think both sides i think this is the
power of being an independent free
thinker that if you're just only saying
i'm on this side
i'm on the i'm a democrat and i agree
with everything or i'm a republican
and i agree with everything it's very
dangerous tell me which part of
policies on the right has changed
policies not positions not
not personality policies
you're saying what since trump has been
in office policies
policies for example let me explain to
what i mean by this yeah did the right
under trump all of a sudden go for
pro-life to pro-choice did the right
all of a sudden under trump go from low
taxes to high taxes
did the right under trump all of a
sudden go from you know protecting the
country with security to now no let's
not do military
that the right under trump all of a
sudden go away from freedom of speech to
now you're being
controlled that so what policies changed
what policies changed on the
uh on uh under obama what policies i
didn't say obama i'm saying under bible
i'm saying
what policy i don't think either side
has changed policies
the problem that uh protecting the
protection of israel has always been
unanimous okay there used to be a time
there used to be a time i sent that
video to you
where we talked about it right where a
lot of the rich country clubs back in
the days
were ran by republicans and they did not
allow jews
right here at the what do you call it
right here right across the street
country club what is the community
called royal palm island
royal pump they did not allow jews to
live in that community but we're talking
50 60 years ago right because it was
like protecting the 50s well
there were sometimes that used to say no
blacks no jews no dogs that's
basically what was going on so that was
then that's how that's how pathetic it
was then right yeah
and so they were welcomed by the
democratic party so the jews said i'm
part of the democratic party because
they welcome me they've had them
for 70 years they've had that vote the
democrats had the black vote for how
many years since
60 60 that's 60 years they've had that
vote right
gradually if they're flip-flopping with
their position of no longer supporting
the jewish community in israel they
could easily lose that vote today
easily lose that that's what i'm saying
what i'm saying the right
didn't change their policies the right
just
hated trump because trump called that
mccain trump called that bush trump
called that bush senior
trump called out a bunch of people who
are veterans on the right saying
i don't care if you're a prisoner of war
i want to make sure you don't get kind
of like some of the comments
that's how he lost a lot of people not
policies
some policies he did change the
tradition such as like free trade
he began trade wars i think the
republicans had a trade war there was
abuse and for many years
everybody wanted to go up against china
but nobody had the audience
credit for that but that's not policies
being a fiscal conservative not taking
on more debt
trump brought on a lot of debt there's
no i mean i think that's the number
i think that's been a uh mutual thing
since
bush obama the last 20 years oh there's
no denying
the democrats don't take on debt but
it's the fact that republicans are
supposed to be more fiscally
conservative
limited under trump i don't trillions of
debts i don't disagree with that but i
think that the big government thing
happened after bush
right after bush everybody wanted a
bigger government that's been happening
for a long time george w bush oh yeah
well after 9 11 and the tsa and
everything yeah big brother
looking at everything bigger and bigger
we've heard more anti-israel talk
in this country in the last three months
than we have in the last 30 years
and yeah and a lot of it's because it's
bds and it's happening on um
boycott divest and um
whatever sanction against israel a lot
of the college campuses a lot of the
let's go back to the woke crowd
something that people need to understand
enough we're gonna go friends on like
the most
ironic part of i think the
the woke liberal left anti-israel bds
is there was a um there was an image
of uh of a gay flag that was essentially
um gays for gaza essentially
and someone pointed out do you
understand that if you
actually that makes no sense had the gay
flag
in gaza they would full on kill you but
if you had that in tel aviv israel they
would just hey good keep
good luck like that's that's the the
biggest
joke is the fact that you have the
liberal woke left
defending these authoritarian
hamas driven terrorist organizations and
that don't understand
how right-wing they are let me put it to
you this is a joke
i've talked about this maybe privately
you and i talked about it there was a
guy back in the days who was like the
the the the jimmy kimmel the jimmy
fallon the
johnny carson of iran his name was faro
saudi
good looking guy very good can you pull
him up there's no way
we're going to be able to spell it hey
would you spell that please
do that f-a-r-o-k-h
z-a-d-e-h no no the fact that you're
even spelling it out
correctly f-a-r-o-k-h
z-a no no put it together it's one name
z-a it's like a john it's an easy name
z-a-d-e
but
h iran put iran okay now go there
put images put images images images
buddy
okay uh go go back uh uh
right there just go right there thank
god that guy right there check it out
okay so he was right there look at this
yeah burt reynolds iranian
man let me tell you good looking guy
great
voice great performer look at that
picture right there of him look at that
that's a that's a sharp looking guy yeah
well anyways there is a
speculation that he was gay in iran and
later well based on that outfit i'm
gonna go
the the speculation was correct then if
that's the case half of men in america
who are metroid
you may not dress like that on the
podcast but you dress like that every
day when you're black and white
black and white does he not dress like
that every day he comes to work you guys
should see how adam dressed
as like a bullfighter i i would like to
be now uh called
salve that's my new name do not butcher
how you better spell that right
anyway so he's about faulk he was gay
you know the rumor had it that he liked
men
yeah and anyways eventually he's at a
hotel in europe
they go find them they chop them up
who's they
the iranians the hezbollah
they find ayatollah they chop them up
and they take his privates they put it
cut him up they put it in his mouth
to prove a point take a picture send it
out that's to say
here's what we do to folks like you for
everybody else we dare you to come out
the closet yeah
do this behavior again see what happens
folks in america think that's a joke
dude in iran would be driving
and if a girl has her hair being shown
back in the days i'm talking the air
when i lived there
back in the days if you had your hair
been shown they would take you they
would take you and whip your back 77
times you would hear that number
constantly
so if you if you see many times when you
go to the beach
and you see a man or a woman in the back
that's got to her their back looks
like what is wrong with this person's
back it's not what's wrong with their
back they got arrested they got whipped
they got lashes in iraq
this was normal in iran it wasn't like
the news cnn eight o'clock tonight
you know jon jones got slashed 77 times
and no it's not like that
just all right cool sounds good all the
best next time don't screw up yeah it's
a different kind of a culture so
many people in america who are saying
gays for gaza
i challenge you to have the courage to
go do that
in actually gaza and see what happens so
if you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye